this is the ramsay
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host and
this is an exciting week for us here at
ramsey we're so thank you thankful you
are with us this is the week we uh
actually launched our very first
full-length
documentary and since i had almost
nothing to do with it i feel like a
proud grandpa the only thing i had to do
with it is my name is on the side of the
building and i paid the people that did
it but i mean they our team did an
incredible world-class job on this
i watched it i was spellbound and i knew
what was going to happen
so you can't miss it it comes out
thursday anywhere great documentaries
are seen
including of course apple tv
google play uh
what am i leaving out i'm even amazon
prime of course yeah so lots of places
that you go to look for good
documentaries you'll see it there you
can watch it at borrowed future.com and
pay us the money if you want instead of
paying those other people the money you
can rent it buy it like anything like
you normally would a big time screen man
it's a cool thing i'm so excited about
it and it's really good it's gonna piss
some people off
which is our entire
goal around here if you are messing with
and hurting people with your process
expect us to be in your grill
and that would include congressmen and
senators
that would include members of higher
education
that would definitely include
sally freaking may
and
uh
the deviant naviant
oh my gosh yeah and so on so there you
go fun stuff yeah check it out borrowed
future spread the word for us we'd love
for this to be a huge success and that
way we could do like another one
because we wouldn't have lost our tail
on this one
was that a little too much information
okay
it's not a great marketing promotion
dave uh triple eight eight two five five
two two five as we talk to you about
your life and your money this is the
ramsay show rick is with us to start
this hour wilmington delaware hi rick
how are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call man
really appreciate it my pleasure how can
i help
hey so i'm i'm 31 we have no personal
debt and i run a construction business
and
we have about um outside of our
emergency fund we have about fifty
thousand dollars of what i would call
investable cash
um and what i wanna do is i would like
to buy a distressed property
and fix it and move into a house like
that now the issue with that as far as
i'm aware i don't think that the bank
will give me
a loan and let me be the gc i couldn't
be mistaken i figured you know more
about that are you agc
yeah technically no i mean you are
licensed as a general contractor oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah they'll let you
do that sure
okay are you now what i had understood
was the bank from what i got from
conversations they said
you cannot gc your own renovation
project oh sure yourself it just depends
on i mean you just hadn't found the
right bank yet but i mean some of them
might not let you but
um
the only question they have you know at
the core of the issue is this
can you do the job will you do the job
they don't want to end up with a loan on
a half-baked
project where you lost your emotional
steam and couldn't finish it
right and so you would need to present
like a plan and stuff
like a budget and a schedule and your
license showing you know how to do this
and
maybe a resume saying i've built this
many properties or renovated this many
properties or whatever i've been in the
business this long and so the banker
goes oh yeah this guy can do it uh how
about uh i've never renovated one i just
passed my license i really don't even
know what a hammer looks like and i just
kind of thought this would be fun banker
says no loan
now if they say no no what are your
thoughts on hard money and paying a
higher down payment
i mean theoretically having more than 50
percent of the value of the house by
taking hard money if that was not an
option to go through the bank
oh about hard money you mean an
unsecured loan at a high interest rate
yes why would you do that when you could
do what i just described how many how
many how long have you been a gc
about six years how many projects have
you run
i've never flipped a house i mean it
doesn't matter have you gc'd anything
of course how many
i mean a hundred okay why can you not
sit down and tell a banker that
i i i just i'm coming for i i don't know
you know i i'm just collecting
information i i assumed because i had
heard people tell me oh you can't people
are ready
you can write this loan you can bank
this loan there you need to go sit down
with your local credit union talk to the
branch manager but don't go sit down
with a dream and a wing and a prayer go
sit down with a freaking plan a budget
right yeah a project management process
and go this is how i'm going to go at it
i want to get pre-approved so i can
start looking for a fixer-upper i've got
50k of my own money to put into this
thing i'm looking at a price range of x
and uh you know and i'm going to need
financing for the rest of it which we
will flip to a permanent mortgage at the
end oh and here's my take-out letter or
or my pre-approval for a takeout letter
from the permanent mortgage company your
local credit union will make this loan
all day long if you have an income and
have paid taxes on an income and you've
done hundreds of projects as a gc
so no you're not gonna go buy a house on
a credit card
that would be dumber than a rock dude
don't do that
all right uh landon is in memphis hi
landon what's up
hey dave i appreciate you taking my call
sure how can i help
uh so i'm 24 and my wife is 23 and we
are about four weeks away from creating
a household
and
yeah appreciate it we have what is your
house right
um about 170
you are a stud how did you do that so
fast
well
and actually we're going to pay it off
in about 10 months once we're done um
until it'll have taken us 10 months we
started out making about 40 grand a year
and then i opened a small carpentry
business and now we're up to about 280
000 a year and we just
just really hate it when that happens
yeah way to go man
appreciate it yeah appreciate it but my
question is is that we're so intense
with what we do
we live on about 1500 bucks a month
right now just because we want our house
payment gone that badly so once we're
done with that okay um you know i i've
read chris hogan's book and uh you know
read probably all the books in your
bookstore twice and every all the
millionaires that i hear or see
say that they went bananas on their
investing once their house is paid off
and so i'm just curious what exactly is
that number in terms of ratio to your
income of you know what is bananas and
giving i mean what is bananas investing
what is outrageous generosity and ratio
to your income or what is you know
really living and having fun with your
income and not being out of balance in
those categories you know obviously
you're not going to invest 100 percent
right and you're not going to give 100
you're not going to spend 100 exactly so
how do we how do we figure that out so
you're on to it though though you're on
to it man you're doing so good way to go
what a great question too so when i'm
when we're coaching people who are
wealthy and you're almost there uh we
tell them there's three things they can
do with money and you need to do all
three intentionally and i don't even
care what the percentages are
you need to spend and enjoy some money
that's number one number two you need to
be generous and number three you need to
be investing you brought all of those up
and so just put a percentage on it
at our house we're christians so we
tithe to our local church and so that's
10 the government takes 40. that leaves
me 50. so when i get in i got 50 going
out before i even burp and and then when
the other the other 50 i need to assign
to those three categories some to
investing some to enjoying and some to
generosity additional generosity in
addition to the tithe and that's what
i've done my whole life since i got my
house paid off and it'll cause you to
become very wealthy happy and healthy
this is the ramsey show
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show open phones at
825-5225
kathy is with us in grand rapids
michigan hi kathy how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
um so i have been through financial
peace university a couple times i've
snowballed myself down to
mortgage payment and student loan
payment student loans will be paid off
for public loan forgiveness in about two
years
my mortgage payment is a 3.1 per 25
percent interest i have about 80 000
left on that
had to get a different vehicle
and this is kind of where the question
starts coming in so
just because of timing and how it worked
out and being out of town and no cars
available
i had intended to use some of
forty five thousand dollars i had saved
to get a new vehicle
i didn't know how i was going to piece
it together but long story short what i
ended up with
was
an auto loan of about 41 000 at 3.99
percent interest that was by mistake i
know i can get a better rate than that
so i'm trying to get in to
refinance that auto loan but then my
questions come in is that really like
what should i do with this 45 000 i have
saved i i'm 55 i only have 25 000 in
mutual funds for retirement
what is your household income
um well that just jumped so it was at 56
000 and then in august it went up to
104.
okay
so i guess you're gonna have to go back
through financial peace university you
flunked
i did with that car thing
horribly yeah you did
and then you just called and asked me
how to refinance a car debt and keep the
car dead while you have the money in the
bank to pay it off
you just did that my
like what real like i really want to
know what's the best thing to do like i
do have the money you know what the best
thing to do is you went through the
class twice
but then i have nothing like i don't
because you bought a car
yeah okay yeah yeah that's one of the
things i've been wondering is if i just
need well here's the thing if you if you
use your 45 000 to become debt free
other than your student loan
which is another problem by the way did
you know that two percent of the public
student loan forgiveness people
actually get it forgiven 98 percent of
not
yeah no i didn't know that so i don't
have a lot of hope for your plan
um how much student loan debt have you
got
um there's 69 000 left okay
all right
so they did recently check it out you
can do what you want to do and obviously
you regularly do that
um so here's what i would tell you to do
okay and this is going to be very
consistent with everything that i taught
you in that class okay okay we're going
to walk the baby steps
you have a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
40 of it is a car
69 is a student loan and you have 45 000
in the bank you have a car you can't
afford you need to sell your car
you need to take 10 000 of the 45 000
and go buy you a 10 000 car
and then you need to use the rest of the
money and pay it on a student loan and
then you need to get on a debt snowball
beans and rice rice and beans on a debt
on a budget where you don't have any
life until you get that student loan
paid off because the federal private
student loan forgiveness program is an
absolute scam i just gave you the real
numbers
98
are not forgiven
two percent have that equals a lot of
people who bet on the government keeping
their word and they were lied to and
you're one of them if i woke up in your
shoes i would treat that student loan
like it was a cancer and i would pay it
off really really fast
get rid of the car and undo the mistake
that i made there
probably got to write a check to do that
god help you a little stupid tax check
there
and then um
you move on from there now you get that
student loan paid off then you build
your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then you start
investing 15
of your household income which in your
case will be 15 000 a year 16 000 a year
until you get your home paid off you're
gonna do all of this by the time you're
60
and and then you're probably going to
have your house paid off shortly after
that if you'll stay on a plan
and quit losing your mind
and driving the car in the ditch no pun
intended
so um but this is what people do and we
all do it we all make mistakes you made
a mistake now you've got a choice are
you gonna are you gonna double down
i'm gonna keep that car well you can you
keep the car that's fine
it's your decision you're like a grown
woman and stuff
so but you call me and made the mistake
of asking me what i would do and then i
am duty-bound to tell you
again
what i would do
hey good luck with it kiddo you call me
if i can help open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
daniel is on the line in orlando hi
daniel how are you
hey dave i'm doing good thank you good
how can i help
um
i me and my wife were
last months were paying off the house
this month
so that's end of all debt
i do have a
own our own business
and i'm at the end of the lease and i'm
looking to purchase office space
and we've been discussing i mean we've
we made an offer on a property as far as
that like at least purchase
um and they have come back with owner
financing i was just wondering
if there was other ways that we can take
care of this yes there are good that's a
great question so you're 100 that free
house and everything
as of this week way to go man
congratulations
it feels pretty dadgum good doesn't it
so last thing we're going to do is jump
back into the fire we finally got out
all right now here's what i did i did
this exact thing for our business many
many years ago
okay i didn't have the money to buy the
office building that we were moving into
it was worth about five million dollars
at the time
and uh and i don't borrow money you
probably heard the rumor so um so i went
to the guy and uh he said well i'll
owner finance it and i said fine here's
how i want the terms to work and these
are to your advantage
i want to pay payments
for lease
exactly like the payments would be with
an option to purchase
and the value of the option goes down
just like the principal would have gone
down
if i don't purchase it
you won't have to foreclose you still
own it
and so i have the option to buy it for
five years
and during that five years i scratched
every nickel out of the corner of the
couch and i bought my first office
building for five million dollars at the
time i closed on it keep in mind i did
this for five years
for five million by the time i closed on
it was worth 12 million
he was crying he did not want me to
close but i had the written written
option so a lease
with a sliding price option to purchase
is exactly the same numbers as an owner
finance but you are not in debt you are
leasing
and he doesn't have to foreclose if you
screw up
he just uh evicts a tenant
that didn't pay their lease on time and
if you don't exercise the option he's
going to have a building that he's got a
ton
of equity in that he's going to be glad
you didn't exercise the option so it's
good for him it's good for you because
you're tying up the property
and you've got a locked in price that
you can buy it at at any time during
that period of time
and now you got your goal with no
payments in the world to start
scratching and clawing come up with
money by that building
otherwise you finance it with a bank
and um or you finance it with him god
forbid you know
and then something like a pandemic or
something like that might happen
and you have no revenue coming in and
you can't um oh and then you get
foreclosed on yeah
see during the pandemic i was really
scared like everybody else was but one
thing i wasn't scared of was foreclosure
because i don't have any mortgages
including the building i'm broadcasting
from which is kind of ridiculous
so but it's just worked out i mean you
keep doing this stuff 30 years it works
and that's where we've been doing it
because i'm like old and stuff
hey man that's how i would do it it's a
good question and you've done really
well congratulations i'm very proud of
you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage david and christy are
with us hey guys how are you
good sir welcome good to have you where
do you live we live in uh corrington
which is outside of knoxville yeah fun i
was born in maryville i'll sleep right
around the corner well welcome guys good
to have you nice to be here all the way
over here to do a debt-free scream how
much did you pay off 85 000 whoa how
long did that take uh it took about 30
months wow and your range of income
during that time uh christian when we
first got married i was making 50 and uh
i'm up to 80. so we're together we're
making close to 100 000 a year all right
very good good for you guys so uh what
kind of debt was the 85 000 uh dave
there was um
stupid debt like credit cards uh i had
financed solar panels
uh we had done some uh renovations to
the house there was a heloc there was a
car and cell phones just kind of normal
yes sir just like normal people most
everybody's that way right
normal sucks though it does yeah so what
happened 30 months ago started on this
ramsey journey uh christy and i were on
our way uh to the outer banks on our
honeymoon and she got to know who dave
ramsey is
there and back oh my gosh
that's not fair yes your honeymoon trip
you put me on yes sir
i learned about you on my honeymoon
literally believable this guy yeah
seriously so um he introduced
me to
um
your
your
beliefs and theories and philosophies um
on how to become debt-free and i just
jumped all in oh just like that
so you you waited until the honeymoon to
spring this on her yes sir never brought
it up before no
i don't know if i admire you or i'm
scared of you
[Laughter]
that's devious
[Laughter]
wow good for you guys how does it feel
to be free two and a half years later oh
my god it's amazing it's amazing we can
lay down at night not knowing that we
can lay down at night knowing that we
don't have anything to worry about yeah
if i lose a job we've got our emergency
fund
everything's taken care of wow you guys
are in great shape
good for you very well done i'm proud of
you
that's a cool thing very cool so um what
was the hardest part of this for you
guys
uh we had both been through bad
relationships
christy was the first person i had
combined my money with in years and
that's hard beginning to trust yeah you
know we
trust each other with our lives
we both had trust issues
that would be normal yeah i mean you get
scars from the other one and it's hard
not to bring that in and make that the
new way of doing things instead you
forced yourself past that discomfort
exactly
but that was hard very hard but it was
it's been well worth it yeah so any big
fights because of that don't like have a
big fight
i mean sure and i do no not really not
really
us putting our money together and
sharing it's it's been a blessing more
than anything you know the weird thing
is is unless they're high unless
somebody's hiding money in that case you
actually know more of what's going on so
it increases trust right which is the
weird thing because i actually know what
you're doing you know what i'm doing
because we are doing it right right and
so it is an easier way to work uh
through that the scars of the past by by
combining it but some people
uh they they just can't face the um
face the ghosts of christmas past so to
speak and uh and you guys were brave
enough to do that well done thank you i
allow him to manage all the money
um pay the bills like the electric and
the water but you know what's going on
oh yeah okay he keeps it on his
telephone so anytime you know he can
bring it up and show me exactly what's
been paid and what we've got in savings
and what we have been checking and then
i have a separate checking
that i use for groceries and for our
children's fans
i have two kids from a previous marriage
and he has a daughter in college in
previous marriage and we sit down on
budget every month and i sit down and go
over what what we have what we're going
to do with it
so everybody knows what's going on yes
sir that's the whole thing right there
right we're completely honest with each
other that that actually uh has the
opposite effect it increases trust which
is opposite of you know the the reason
people don't do it and so uh very good
way to go guys thank you good start for
the marriage too that's neat
very very fun all right what advice do
you have somebody's listening and they
go i just got married i got trust issues
from the former one and i just i don't
know man it's i don't know can you do
this if you're not 22 and you know can
you do this if you're a little bit older
than 22 or 25 years old or whatever what
advice do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is for you guys
you've got to work together
you have to believe in each other and
believe in what you're doing and know
that it's for a purpose
higher than
just you know you're not planning for
tomorrow or next week you're planning
for five years down the road 10 years
down the road 20 years down the road
and i work with a young young man he's
26 his name's josh
and i'm constantly we're we're talking
about finances
so he he kind of
he listens and i think i'm probably got
him going toward the dave ramsey track
all right i've got a 12 year old and a
14 year old and he has a 20 year old
and guess what they got for christmas
last year tell them they got fpu
we have infected your whole family
and my 11 year old at the time
actually wrote a report on it and he
separated all of his money into the save
the give
and
the other spin packet yeah that's fun
very good well way to go you guys again
we're very proud of you here
congratulations your heroes your heroes
you push through some difficult stuff
and uh this stuff is uh this thing
called transformation
changing into something you weren't
before it's a hard thing
and it it's it's uh it's not for the
weak of heart
it requires uh it requires some backbone
and you guys did it i'm very very proud
of you heroes taking control of your
life great job we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in your story to be everyday
millionaires you might already be there
who knows
and uh now that you knocked all this out
very cool place to be and a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away and infect someone else's honeymoon
maybe
it's not the first time i've heard that
story but you were a little bit brutal
with that i said hey hon let's go to the
outer banks and listen to this all the
way over there
but it worked out i love it very cool
david and christy knoxville tennessee 85
000 paid off in 30 months making 50 all
the way up to now 100 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two
one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
this is how it is done boys and girls
this is how it's done don't miss that
very very cool stuff
oh man
you know there's two sides of this um
money equation there's offense and
defense offense is
investing your money well
defense is getting out of debt defense
is having the right insurance in place
so once you finally get stuff all lined
up then
something happens
you don't have to start over
and so most americans don't have enough
car insurance as an
example you might be one of them you get
into an accident you don't have enough
insurance you have to pay for your own
car repairs your own medical bills
of course the other drivers car repairs
and their medical bills and their
passengers medical bills it can be
thousands and thousands of dollars you
got to have the right car insurance
it's one of the reasons we created the
network of endorsed local providers
these are insurance brokers they don't
work for one company they shop among a
bazillion different companies and get
you the best possible deal
the best value on the coverage that you
actually need the right amount of
coverage not too much not too little
but with somebody that actually is
working for you they're shopping for you
to get the best deal you want to learn
about that the average person doing this
saves about 700 bucks so and it's free
to check it out doesn't cost a thing to
get a quote
you can't argue with free for maybe 700
i'll take free for maybe 700. text auto
233 789
to connect with a ramsey trusted elp for
car insurance text auto 233789
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
this is a wonderful american success
story of this company they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure when you're ordering
your window blinds maybe you're like me
you pick the wrong color i always do
that they'll remake your window blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with new promos all the
time you save even more always use the
promo code ramsey our question of the
day was i was listening to the show when
you talked about the types of insurance
we need i started looking on your site
and we saw a shield by the protection by
the providers names what does that mean
well that's the thing we've just
instituted in the last few months what
we figured out was
that when i endorse something
like a smart investor pro and elp xander
insurance churchill mortgage those kinds
of companies which all of those i've
endorsed for decades literally
um that really what you the reason you
would go to them
is because you trusted me
and you trusted me because and you
trusted them because i trusted them
and you trusted me to be trusted right
so it was trusted so we started calling
it ramsey trusted
and they put a little shield on these
companies if they're ramsey trusted now
what we do
our team does this
is we will not put a ramsey trusted
shield on someone unless we've done
detailed in-depth
uh
you know vetting on these guys and
they're reliable
they line up with our mission
uh you know they have to be a quality
company that's doing stuff the way we do
it
in order for us to endorse them and put
the ramsey trusted
shield beside them
and so um
you know like the good housekeeping seal
of approval except this one actually
means something i'm not saying that one
doesn't but i really if i am a customer
and i'm buying something the good
housekeeping
i have no idea what that means
i don't know what they did in order if
that window is good housing it might be
that they put it through rigorous
testing i don't know i'm a customer
consumer and i don't know that so i'm
telling you what this is this is a seal
that we it means that we've done
extensive work
on that company with that company and we
trust them and the rule of thumb that we
use around here is are they reliable
enough are they competent enough do they
line up with the advice we give here do
they have the heart of a teacher you
know all right and are are they gonna
take great care of you would i send my
own
best friend there
and if they would then we put the seal
on it now i gotta be truthful with y'all
i've been on radio for almost 30 years
in the early days we were so desperate
to sell ads
that i endorse things not that we're
evil or bad but i just
kind of cringed when i did it because i
needed we needed the money
and it wasn't a sellout but it kind of
was
because it was like and i finally
started asking myself if i if my friend
went over there would i be okay with
that and i'm like ooh
and i just don't want that feeling in
the back you know that's on the back of
your tongue when you do something like
that and it's like greedy or whatever
you call it i don't know it was just
short-sighted
and um
man i just i had i hit a point early in
my career i mean i probably 25 years ago
or something like that that i just said
you know what i don't need money that
bad
even if i need money i don't need it
that bad
even if we're trying to accomplish some
kind of goal i don't need money that bad
and i don't really care how much money
it is i don't want that feeling that i
would send one of you guys who i've
never met
there
and then if my friend called me well
dave did you really
would you really go to that mattress
company
and if i went ooh no i'd never go over
there i just thought it was a it was
just an ad
but i put my voice on it my reputation
my name on it or one of the other mg
personalities did and ramsay then stood
behind that company and we're going ooh
see we don't do that
we just don't do that that's what the
shield means it's trusted it means we
would send our best friend over there
and we'd send anybody that works here
out of our thousand team members over
there and so we feel proud
to send you over there
not to see perfect people because i
hadn't met any of those
except some of you that [ __ ] all the
time
but um
and your that proves you're not perfect
but um but there's no perfect people out
there and so there's no perfect
companies or perfect experiences but i
am proud to
endorse my friend jeff zander at xander
insurance for over 20 plus years over 25
years i guess it is now
he's become a personal friend all of my
personal insurance is there and if
you're my best friend and you call me up
offline
at my house in the evening dave would
you really go to the jefferson yeah i
did and yeah you should go over there
it's where you're gonna get the best
price on your life insurance shut up
and they're great people to work with so
i mean that's what the little shield
thingy means
is like would you send your friend there
any of you got a friend that if he tells
you she tells you to go see a movie it's
an automatic no i'm not going that movie
because they have no taste in movies
i've got one of those friends his name
is tom
and if tom says go that movie it's a
hundred percent guarantee i'm not going
he sent me to a movie one time called
dude where's my car
this is his taste in movies
which is a classic cult kind of a movie
now i guess
about a couple of stoners who lost their
car right but um
but uh you know this is tom's taste in
movie so if he sends you there you don't
you don't trust tom anymore for that and
that's how ramsay trusted works we want
to be the opposite of tom's movie picks
[Laughter]
trustworthy worthy
of
trust
christopher is with us christopher's in
duluth minnesota hi christopher how are
you
i'm great thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
all right so i am a 54 year old father
of six he is seven to 18. we're in baby
step seven but i've got a baby step five
question cool
my oldest daughter is a freshman and she
very unexpectedly
was rewarded a full-ride scholarship
wow
good for her
yeah i was uh in my second my son my
second oldest
he's already enlisted um he graduates
early and goes in the military in
december
so my question is is
and they're paying for it
right right
all right so we have
uh we have been very blessed we have 400
000 in our 529
we tell the kids if you earn your first
year of school with scholarships or work
we will pay 30 a year the next three
years
we we've met that goal now because of
her getting that scholarship
do i put all that money into a money
market do i keep it spread across the
funds
um
she got a free ride for one year
no for the whole four years you're gonna
pay her 30 a year
thirty thousand dollars
she paid for her first year school she
got that money back now we were gonna
give her 30 a year
for for the rest the other three years
like to help her with tuition right
i mean
she doesn't need tuition she's got a
free ride i'm confused
right so so what are you doing with the
30 a year now
it's it's it's in this 529 i know but
what was your plan to do with it now
that she got a free ride you don't have
to give her 30 a year you're planning to
give it to her anyway
no no it's gonna go to her brothers and
sisters ah so that's that's the deal
with you know okay
okay she didn't get any of that she's on
her own uh sort of on her own and we'll
kind of help her but she's on her own
because she got the scholarship okay and
so your only question is how to
distribute it whether you move it to
money market or whether you leave it
invested
right since i would leave an investment
leave an investor we've invested okay
yeah because the difference is
substantial even if the uh even if the
investments do poorly they're still
going to be four or five x what that
money market's going to be
okay unless they went down i mean they
just you know they could go down who
knows
you know
our next child is 14 and i'm just
worried well if there's a downturn then
we'd be below
because we have
four a certain
three of the next four or one year apart
yeah but before there's a down i mean it
would have to be a substantial downturn
to be me to mess you up and an extended
and extended and substantial like go in
half and stay down five years
okay which would be like there's only
two times in history that's happened in
the united states okay so i i'm not
worried about that one now i don't think
this affects your plan
but just for clarification for those
listening like in the case of your
daughter if you get the paperwork from
the school showing the value of the
scholarship you are allowed to remove
that much from the 529 tax free and turn
that in on your you have to file a form
with your tax return but you're allowed
to remove that much say she got a 13 000
scholarship for tuition for the year you
can take 13 out with no taxes and no
penalties but you need to pair it up
with paperwork in case of an audit and
make sure everything's taken care of
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice christie wright ramsay
personality two-time number one
best-selling author is my co-host
this hour if you want your question
answered call in the phone number is
triple eight
eight two five five
two two five her new book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance debuted
number one on the best seller list way
to go christy thanks for the job so
exciting yeah proud of you proud of our
team the hard work they did on the
marketing but the book is excellent
guilt-free guide to life balance is
really important this is a big week for
the business boutique brand your first
your first number one bestseller uh
we've got a whole group of over a
thousand almost two thousand people
coming into nashville for the business
boutique conference live and we're live
streaming it that's right and you're
going to let me speak this year you say
that every year
i'm very generous like that you are
you're generous that way you're just
kind
with the conference that i own you let
me come i just no one's falling for that
for one second everybody knows everybody
knows better every time you say that oh
well it's going to be a lot of fun it is
uh they come in thursday night yep and
then friday and saturday all day yep and
uh i'll be on stage i understand on
friday yep and um it is quite a lineup
of speakers and we've still got some
seats left it is and it's one of those
things where every single year we raise
the bar every single year we look at the
survey results from the year before we
we always want to hit on the topics that
people struggle with the most so when we
talk about managing the money in your
business selling how to sell without
feeling slimy or wanting to you know
annoy people that's not what it is we
teach them how to sell with confidence
we talk about marketing social media we
talk about pushing past your fear
because that's such a big piece of any
of this stuff having the time making the
time to work on your business and having
a plan so these are the main buckets
that we hit every year but we hit it
with new speakers from new angles we
keep the content fresh but every single
time we have a lot of fun and you leave
fired up to go chase your business yeah
people come in kind of looking around
unsure and by the time they leave they
are jacked yeah yeah because they've got
not only the information but the
inspiration so dr john dolone speaking
of course uh our friend monique shohan
if you guys don't know monique she's a
local uh restaurant tour that's uh often
on the food channel yeah you see her on
there all the time she owns a bunch of
restaurants necessarily an incredible
entrepreneur cool lady yeah she's a lot
of fun yeah and so she'll be a great
addition jasmine star will be with us
nona jones and bianca oltof yep so what
are nona and bianca speaking out so
bianca is a faith-based speaker we
always like to have one session that is
just highly inspirational biblical truth
she'll be on thursday night with me and
i've actually never met her but know of
her we run in the same circles and uh
women you know the the the kind of
christian bible teacher circle uh with
tbn that type of thing and so she's
amazing and then um nona jones has a
really cool story she is um she's got a
story of past trauma so she helps people
overcome trauma um pursue success and
she has some really cool teaching um
specifically on working from the inside
out so working on your thoughts
controlling your thoughts your the power
of of your mind and so on and then
working that out in your actions in your
day to day so she's also by the way an
expert on social media and so she has
pioneered the church division at
facebook and so she's going to share
some social media teaching as well oh
that's interesting yeah very cool very
cool the business boutique conference
equipping women to make money
doing what they love so they'll be
mainly ladies there and uh certainly
anybody's welcome it's a three-day event
this coming weekend just a few days away
here in nashville
tickets are just 119
if you want the event passes you can do
the live stream as well
if you want more information text
boutique 233
789 text boutique 233
789 we'd love to have you here in
nashville nashville is a great place to
visit anyway but this is an incredible
incredible conference and you don't want
to miss out on this again just a few
tickets left but we can still get you in
i know a guy john's in chattanooga hey
john welcome to the ramsey show how can
christy and i
help dave good
thank you for taking my call how you
guys doing great man what's up
so i just recently bought a primary
residence um
i've been kind of doing the investing
bit myself about a year now so far so
good you know been great
i've been using the same home inspector
he's been very thorough he's always been
very helpful and informative whenever i
go with him showing me this or you know
teach me more here and there
so this house uh everything was good and
everything so day one when i first you
know finally closed and we moved in
day one i knew there was something wrong
with the hvac system and you know i was
reaching out to the realtor just be like
you know hey
did we hear anything was there any i
mean i know despite sellers disclosure
but um
so
i actually had a internet guys what
found the problem and then i've had
different ac companies come in
and they were telling me that you know
the words i used to describe the
oversight of the ductwork was
catastrophic was he blindfolded did he
even go underneath the house
and you know to the point of
each quote that i got to even fix the
hvac system is a pretty significant cost
how much
um well i
understand there's different efficient
working and like repairing what needs to
be done
but we're talking maybe eight to ten
thousand on the good side not including
insulation issues that that he missed
eight to ten thousand dollars worth of
duct work that was not plugged in and
not done right
uh just in ruins and just how many how
many different estimates have you gotten
estimates yeah for fixing the ductwork
uh
three estimates for the duct work and i
had two for the insulation all kind of
be in the
climate control issue insulation of the
house or the insulation of the ductwork
insulation of the house okay how much
for the ductwork
does work looking about three or four
thousand okay and to that point you want
to spend five thousand dollars on
insulation on your house how big a house
is this no
that's just for the duct work the
insulation was about 2500
that's not eight thousand
three and two is five
three and two is five the with the
different ac companies and they all
remarkably said the same thing
the unit's too small for the house but
because the house is originally made as
a barn and been added to it so the floor
levels are
different as far as like underneath the
house okay do you think this guy was
smoking dope or do you think he
intentionally ripped you off or do you
think he just made an honest mistake
out of referrals and just kind of
networking by understanding he's still
kind of feeling this way so he could be
a little more green i couldn't presume
to say because did you bring this
problem to him
i did what did he say
initially it was great to hear that he
was you know willing to own up very well
could have overlooked and i was like
that's awesome but you know going to the
quote you know it's kind of like well
everything was working good you know at
time of the inspection and
so on and so forth but
you know 10 days after living there you
know the closet right next hvac system
was consumed with mold growing into the
bedroom right next to it from the you
know humidity in there
uh
he's just keep kind of splitting hairs a
little bit it seems and he's more like
i'm more than happy to consult and you
know do all this and that but definitely
trying to stay away from
you know as far as
lending a hand in the financial repairs
finances for repairs i kind of smell
that you're heating an air guys trying
to make a sale
i might be wrong
but i think he's added some drama to
this
you bought a barn with an air
conditioner on it
i might be wrong i think i'd tread
carefully here i think your feelings are
hurt i tread careful
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data with no
contract the average family saves over
70 dollars a month by switching to pure
top just go to feartalk.com and enter
the promo code ramsey to save 50 off
your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
chrissy wright number one best-selling
author of the brand new bestseller for
her take back your time the guilt-free
guide to life balance is my co-host
today as we take your questions we were
talking with john in chattanooga he
bought a uh a barn that is converted to
a home the unit and it's been added on
to the heat and air unit is too small
the ductwork was not connected there was
mold and there was a lack of insulation
his home inspector seemed to have missed
this his heat and air guy asked if the
guy was blindfolded when he did the home
inspection
um and so
uh okay john here's what's bothering me
in this in this story are you with me
still
okay here's what's bothering me
uh your heating and air guy
uh who stands to benefit from getting
this job
is
blowing this up
and really running down the other guy
the other trade
if the only way i can get work is to run
down the other guy
and i can increase the size of my ticket
i no longer trust
his voice his voice is bothering me in
this story
is that fair entirely okay entirely yeah
and you had a guy that prior to this you
trusted
now have you been under there and looked
at this stuff
yes i have and i know honestly i'm not
an ac guy but i'm not either but
apparently if he wasn't blindfolded he
could have told
according to this other guy he could
have told it wasn't connected right
yeah any rooms of the house not being
connected whatsoever
how many rooms
uh three rooms
okay used to be more but it was opened
up since it's been uh there for so long
okay
so um
i've got a question so
let's say that he did totally screw up
is there any liability it would depend
on what your contract says with your
home inspector
as to how much liability he has limited
and it sounds like he's not a big time
home inspector some of them actually
carry insurance for arizona missions
that cover the recovery if they miss
something so i would investigate those
two things that's a good question is
what does the actual agreement state
that he's liable for in the event he
misses something like this
uh also find out if he has insurance to
cover it now past that let's get
practical
this guy's a small timer he's gotten he
doesn't have three or four thousand
dollars to give
you of course even if he wanted to
i mean i don't think you're going i
don't think you're going to get any
money out of it huh
well yeah of course i don't really want
any money out of him per se but we did
speak in regards to you know what
contingency could there be if there was
oversight you know
that on his end he does have insurance
to cover it and you know of course an
inspection of inspection of that time i
don't mind to cover you know the
insulation and just
everything else i need to take care of
but just inside of it being an oversight
considerable oversight
i'm just curious of your guys thoughts
so i just go ahead and eat it and just
pay for myself yeah i mean if you can
get an insurance a check out of his
insurance guys i i would if you really
believe he had an oversight
um because i but i don't think this guy
is going to give you any money because i
don't think he has any money
and i think it's probably the last time
you're going to use him as an inspector
right
that's both both statements are fair
yeah i i um but i and i'd get the
insurance money out of him if i could
because it sounds like he did miss it if
this if you can get it i i don't know
how complicated it is i've never filed a
claim on something like that so um i
don't know what it is but i also am a
little bit disturbed i think you're
heating there guys overstating this and
adding some drama trying to make a sale
my guess is you've done some rehabs that
you probably can get
a good sub in there and uh you know get
some
bad insulation bat insulation not bad
and uh get the thing in you know
it sounds like some flex duct run to
those other rooms if they and you're
probably gonna have to upgrade your unit
at some point it's not gonna carry the
whole thing
uh so you know you're gonna lose on this
transaction you're gonna eat some of it
um
and
you know that's
i don't know i don't know way around
that in this situation because here's
the thing i've figured out and chrissy
this is a good principle for business in
general
it's so frustrating when somebody
doesn't do their job
but when they're broke
the contract you signed with them
actually means almost nothing because
they're they're only going to abide by
the contract to the extent they have the
resources to abide by the conflict but
they can they can't they don't
physically have the money yeah and so
even if the guy went yep my bad yeah um
he's got you know if he says my bad and
i got he's got a hundred thousand
dollars in bank account write you a
check that's good but that's not
normally the case in something like this
contracts don't make bad deals good
contracts don't make bad people good
contracts don't make incompetent people
competent and so never sign a contract
and this is not what he was doing by the
way i'm not picking on john but never
sign a contract because i've done this
and i would go and then the whole thing
would blow up and i kind of knew it was
a bad deal but i signed a contract and
then i say the dumbest statement here's
what i would say and some of you have
said this
but i have a contract
as if it had magical powers yeah to make
the incompetent competent the crooked
straight yeah it doesn't contracts don't
have magical powers if you just clarify
what two good capable people were going
to do that they do they have
communication tool for doing what they
say they're going to do that's all a
contract does yeah it's a false sense of
security if you think it's going to
fill a gap that can't be filled by a
contract by a piece of paper yeah
or you get the wonderful opportunity
going to court yeah to try to you know
and then you're just throwing good money
after bad and i've done that and i i
probably will have to do that again in
business sometimes i have to go before
the judge and go this bozo's doing this
and i can't get him to stop and yeah you
know and so you gotta you gotta do it
but
she's it's a it's a no it's no win
because it does just cost you money when
people wins the lawyers yeah but well
going back to the heat and air guy you
make a good point too because i was
thinking about this when you were
talking about him and maybe maybe a
layer of drama there of exaggerating and
the whole blindfold comment when you
exaggerate
what's going on even if there are
oversights and issues you lose
credibility when you act in this
exaggerating drum dramatic state and so
wait a minute that's my job
wait a minute this is what we do for a
living
except the truth is a suggestion i like
to add a little flair uh but no it's
like so so some people in sales are
trying to you know get a sale they
exaggerate so much that they make the
person scared it's this fear tactic yeah
and a scared person even that it doesn't
lead to good deals it doesn't lead to
good decisions so so even if the guy had
some some valid points the drama takes
away the credibility of of him as a as
the person you want to go to i don't
want to go to him even if he's right i
want to go to someone that seems more
credible yeah and they go gosh it's a
horrible situation how can i help you
solve your problem that's exactly right
it says you know what he overlooked it
he may have been new hey just a more
common sense level-headed approach to
assessing the situation versus this
dramatic scene yeah yeah john i i'm
afraid you're eating a lot of this my
friend all of that to say that
oh adrian's with us in miami hi adrian
how are you
hi babe it is truly an honor to speak
with you youtube what's up
yeah well i am apparently 20 years old
and i make 50 000 a year i graduated
this summer with an engineering degree
and i have saved up since my whole life
a little less than 60 000. i meant your
phone is mumbling can you speak directly
into your mumbling phone
yes sorry about that can you hear me
better yeah much better thank you
okay yeah so um i have saved up a little
less than 60 000 and i have been um
looking to move out of my friend's house
but i live in miami and
the rents are incredibly high and so i
want to get your opinion on what i
should do
i know that uh you recommend
that you find a place with a mortgage or
a rent that is less than 25 of your
take-home pay which i haven't been able
to find that yet
how old are you again adrian
20 years old
adrian you're making 50 grand you're
making
you can find something it may not be in
the exact neighborhood you want maybe
with a roommate
you can find lots of people live on less
than you do with a family
yeah so
i so what i've been able to find are
like mortgage or rents
about like one thousand dollars and yeah
25 of my take-home pay would be around
700 which is what scares me yeah so you
need to keep looking you haven't found
the right place yet
but
christie's numbers are exactly right you
do live in an expensive city and you may
have to move out of the city a little
bit you may have a bit of a commute
you may be looking for a garage
apartment out back at some rich old
lady's house and you rent the garage
rent the apartment over her garage or
something like that
you may be picking up a roommate or
three
but you can afford to do this
maybe your parents job is to make you a
little more uncomfortable
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones triple eight
eight two five five
two two five felicia is with us in
louisville hey felicia how are you
hey hey jay good how are you great how
can we help
yeah um so my husband uh we just started
at fpu and very recently like our first
official month really you know going all
in on it cool my question is
we have about twelve thousand dollars in
debt and we're doing this all backward
because we just started um so we have 12
000 in debt we do have about 15 in
savings though okay um
should we go ahead and also i'm going to
be needing a new car
very soon and i have 155 000 miles on
mine
and i love it
it is it is it's an explorer and i love
it but it's just it's just it's just
about to lay down you're afraid it is
yes and we have three kiddos so that's
the thing in car seat so i'm going to
need something that is full size that's
not
not going to be too cheap you know and
so my question is should we go ahead and
pay off the 12 000 in debt from our
savings
and then i i'm not taking a car payment
um or getting a loan for that
i don't know i'm kind of
stuck right now with this
what's your household income
um my husband just started a new job but
this is in january so right now he's
gross over a hundred thousand
but we take home about six grand a month
and i stay at home with my kiddos okay
well i mean i think one of the things
that's that feels scary about this
felicia is that you know you want a car
soon but the good news is you don't need
a car right now
right now you have the savings to pay
off that debt and you're debt-free like
today
you could say that's a good income you
could save up and that that car may lie
i mean this is speaking from someone
that you know i have driven cars into
the ground in the past and it may go a
lot longer than you think um you don't
need anything right now you've got them
you'll have some emergency fund left
over anyway already your your baby step
three which is your three to six months
of emergency fund
you'll have that started with a few
grand and so if you have a repair you
need to make in the next few months when
you're saving up you can cover it make
it last a little longer and then you can
save up and pay cash for another
used
suv or whatever you need but you'll be
able to buy it in cash i think it just
feels scary because it's high mileage
but it's if it's running it's running if
right if one of your
kids was sick
and you needed money bad to pay the dock
what's the most
out of your six grand
you could save a month if you had to
well we do have an hsa and we put 50
a week into that and what does that have
to do with what i just asked you
i don't know
what is the most um we could do one of
your kids
no i don't understand because you had an
hsa okay i was trying to use i was
trying to use a metaphor and we got
sidetracked into a product okay
okay now it does make sense it was my
fault okay i just i was
okay you went you went straight to the
real answer and i was trying to do okay
my point is out of that six grand if you
had to the world came to an end how much
is your house payment
um about thirteen hundred dollars a
month okay so you could save three grand
a month if you had to
if you had no payments except a house
payment
exactly okay so what i would do is pay
off all your debt today
and start saving three grand a month
until you have an emergency fund and
then keep saving until you have enough
money to buy a car in cash
okay my heart just went down to my
stomach because i'm excited i'm scared
to do that
good you did a good job you did a good
job you actually answered the question i
was trying to be metaphorical and i i
screwed it up so
my bad
but the uh uh but see my point is with
no payments and your newfound
intentionality with money on paper on
purpose with both you and your husband
on the same team christie's answer is
exactly correct
that you can save up an emergency fund
if things blow up while you have that
emergency fund before you have the
car
then you'd have to use the emergency
fund because it'd be an emergency to buy
a little better car right
right but but you're going to be just
fine because you know
you said you've got 15 right
yeah so we got three there now next
month we'll have six the next month we'd
have nine the next month we'd have
twelve
that's christmas
you got twelve thousand dollars in the
bank at christmas and no payments in the
world
i and i think your car is gonna make it
to christmas
i think so yeah yeah i just only hit
that weekend that i'm going oh now we
have to go you know
we'll get a new firefight yeah well
don't don't
don't turn it into
i got forced in to do something stupid
because you already put on the table i'm
not doing car payments you're smart
there that was wise so you got this got
the right track and so if and if buying
a car becomes an emergency slow down
breathe just a little bit but if you can
fix the old one for 500 and get another
six months out of it do that too because
i want you to save up and pay cash for a
ten thousand dollar car and still have
twelve thousand dollars in your account
and still have no payments
okay and that's that's uh
april
yeah okay
and you can do this
by april yeah i think so too
okay so hey thank you thanks for the
call that's a really good question so
what happened there well i was actually
going to ask you a follow-up question
that because i think that sometimes we
and i've heard this on the ramsey show
several times people call in and they
say well this is my situation so should
i either pause the baby steps or leave
this extra money in savings because and
there's only a couple scenarios that you
say to do that so when you're when
you're expecting uh yeah i remember we
talked about this last year in the
pandemic someone had lost their job or
were thinking they were gonna lose their
job will you unpack that really quickly
what are the scenarios where we say
let's pause the baby steps stockpile
cash because of this unique circumstance
all other circumstances like for example
150 000 miles on your car i'm like oh in
my mind because i'm like old school
you could have a few years in that car
you're good put some new tires on it get
some of that fresher smell stuff and
right down there at walmart all three
you'll be good i'm telling you my 1996
jeep grand cherokee that thing smelled
like a go-kart it smelled like a goat
because you had actual goats in it
christie that's a fact and that's
actually a that's gross
the goat mobile you're the goat lady i
never knew that i did not have a trailer
i have a number one best-selling author
formerly known as the goat lady i mean i
feel like that's my next stage of my
brand like
we may have a break a marketing
breakthrough right here on the air
there's there's so many people that know
those old farm stories and they're like
oh the fainting tell the fancy story but
back back to your question anyway talk
about the scenarios in which like 150
000 miles is not one of them let's talk
about the scenarios that where you would
say yes let's stop paul cash in this
scenario
facts
are what we deal with not feelings
the feeling is
in her case and she was being very
logical about it she did a really good
job
her critical thinking skills were right
there yes but what what this is is the
feeling is this car's gonna go out at
any moment the insecurity of driving an
older car with three little kids that's
right that's a feeling it rises up it
rises up and it grabs you by the throat
it doesn't it doesn't come from the head
down it comes from the stomach up yeah
you know what i'm saying
and
when that makes your financial decisions
you're going to be broke your whole life
a fact is
the car is in the driveway with smoke
coming out from under the hood it's done
that's a different fact right then i'm
afraid
that it's going to lay down and it
probably will lay down at some time in
the future and we'll just have to put a
bullet in it
and so um
the uh uh
so what you've got to do is go okay and
the facts are when we laid the math out
we're not suggesting you drive this 150
000 mile car for eight years
or suggesting it for eight months
because in eight months you can with
your newfound tools in financial peace
university you can accomplish a ton of
goals and get some space behind you now
the fact is
that if you have a baby on the way and
you push pause on your total money
makeover
baby steps and your your financial peace
debt snowball and you quit paying extra
on the debt and you pile up cash until
baby comes and mommy comes home from the
hospital with baby everybody's in good
shape no troubles then we take all that
cash except a thousand dollars when we
restart
all you lost was the interest on
that amount of money
now i might lose my job in the future is
everyone
yep
everyone might lose their job in the
future not me i work for the government
you might lose your job in the future
i'm just saying you could lose your job
in the future that is a a universal
worry
now that is not a fact that's a feeling
it is a fact but it's a the probability
of it
they just announced
that we're all going to be laid off in
four weeks that's a fact right you stop
everything and you get ready but i'm
kind of worried about this because of
the pandemic and people around and i
just generally worry about a lot of
stuff and no that's not a fact that's a
feeling you don't stop on that you plow
through so facts and feelings facts and
feelings help you decide whether to stop
or not this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today her book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance debuted a couple of weeks ago as
a number one best seller her second
number one best seller this coming
weekend we have the business boutique
conference uh be just under a couple
thousand folks there there's a couple
seats available if you still want to
come uh you can text um whatever
boutique
text boutique to 33 789 there it is
right in front of me
and uh we'd love to have you i'll be
speaking christy dr john deloney and
several other keynote ladies that are
just absolutely incredible it is the
business boutique conference equipping
women to make money doing what they love
i think this is our fifth one
or sixth well if you count the one days
i mean we're at like 16. holy crazy yeah
remember there for the first couple
years we did all over the country so
yeah
fall of 2015 was the first
fall event but we've done about 15 or
16. all right so this is the sixth one
of those yep then the all the the big
involvement yeah okay
wow
and it's been very very popular
obviously so we've continued to do them
and hey if you want to visit nashville
ladies it's a good excuse for you to
come down here you will come in not
knowing how to do things and leave
completely equipped it's pretty
incredible conference
so again text boutique
23789 and i don't want to miss out on uh
mentioning the calendar because we ain't
got many left yeah the goal planner so
the 22 goal planner we launch at this
time of year because that's when most
people buy their planners for the
following starts in january but it does
sell out every year i always remind
people when i talk about this year last
year it sold out earlier than ever
before it sold out like beginning of
december but it was too late to do a
reorder and so yeah if you're wanting
this for christmas shipping has been
weird across the country go ahead and
get your copy for a gift or whatever
you're thinking to make sure you don't
miss it old planner does what
this is your calendar but it's also your
tool for setting and keeping your goals
so you've got monthly teaching you've
got templates to help you put that
teaching into practice journal questions
and then of course calendar to-do list
all the things to keep you organized but
i think the most important part of it is
the fact that we carry goals through the
year so in april and in august you're
revisiting those goals saying are they
right do we need to change something
about them has something in your life or
your season change so it's a great
companion to help you stay on track and
do what you say you want to do all the
way through and we sell tens of
thousands of them every year and um
honestly the these um
shortages and everything else are giving
us fits in the publishing side but we've
got them uh uh the chances used to we
could just reorder with five days or
something this year not a chance yeah so
when they're gone they're probably gone
yeah unless we just little strike a
little gold
you know gold rush thing or something
but i doubt it so you need to get that
while you got the chance doug is with us
in kansas hi doug welcome to the ramsey
hey
show
it going guys better than we deserve
what's up
hey quick question for you so me and my
wife are on baby step number two
and uh we're having a baby that's due in
january yay
congratulations well thank you uh so my
question is i hear you guys talk about
it and i don't know if i've missed it a
time or two but to go in the stork mode
and that's what we're kind of doing
right now
but my question is i'm just trying to
plan
for it but when do you
no longer
do stork mode and then you you go back
on to hitting it hard
yeah we were just talking about this
literally right before the break doug
the the idea is while you're expecting
you can pause your baby steps stockpile
some cash you've got some extra savings
uh just for all the you know any
unexpected complications which we hope
and pray doesn't happen but if it does
you've got some savings there then once
your wife and the baby you're home
safely and all that good stuff you know
a month or two months in you start you
you know everybody's home safe you're
all settled you go ahead and get back
into those baby steps and i think the
the biggest thing i hear from people
when they call when they're expecting is
just this unknown it's the fear of the
unknown it's the fear of how much is a
baby going to cost how many diapers is
going to cost you just make this a line
item in your budget the things you're
not currently purchasing like diapers
for example um you begin to budget for
and so it's not as scary and
unpredictable as it seems when you are a
new parent or becoming a new parent but
you begin to plan for it and so yeah
just a couple months a month you know a
month month month
and then get back at it just your first
baby in it
um
uh no this is actually uh my second oh
it's a
it's a boy uh my first was it was my
daughter uh
unfortunately
we had a crisis and uh last year
november she passed away she was still
born god
oh doug i'm so sorry oh
well thank you well yeah i'm just tired
so you asking this question about not
knowing how to be secure in this
situation with what you've been through
means you're a good human
because you're you're you know you got a
lot of raw nerves here man you got a lot
of i can't even i can't breathe and it
wasn't even my situation just talking to
you so
um yeah and so if you want to uh stay in
stork mode a little bit longer
but you probably mechanically
mathematically don't need to but i think
we can set aside the idea that
emotionally you might want to
yep and that's that's kind of where i'm
at because stuff scares you more than
yep stuff scares you more than
maybe otherwise would have in this
situation so
oh man what a deal to go through i'm so
sorry yeah and congratulations on the
new one yeah so um well thank you so
it's uh uh the best of times and the
worst of times all at the same time it's
kind of hard to figure out right
oh yeah very excited yeah yeah
yeah and so given the the tragedy that
you all been through if you want to
uh hunker down have a little more cash
for a little while just as a
medication for a little bit
and normally i'd say one month but if
you want to make it three
that's not the other world if you want
to make it 30
you probably need to think about who
you're talking to as a counselor about
walking through your grief then
okay can i ask you another quick
question sure
okay so she's wanting to take off uh
her 12 weeks for maternity leave which
is 100 we both agree let's do it
um we have money saved aside for that
here in a little few months or in a few
months or a few weeks we'll have about
eight thousand dollars to cover her side
of expenses and whatnot
so
once she's back at work and saying
should we start then or should we yeah
that's another that sounds really good
okay
and you don't have to spend the 8 000
unless you have to have it to eat while
she's not working
yeah no i think we're we're okay with
that just let that sit there and then
yeah ride the 12 weeks that sounds like
a good number
give yourself a little grace yes a
little uh a little room
uh because of what you all been through
give yourself a little wiggle room
emotionally here okay
yeah
and that's what money's for by the way
is to give you a little margin
so the edges on everything aren't quite
as rough money won't solve it for sure
not even close
but uh but but it gives you it gives you
the ability to worry about the right
things instead of the wrong things yeah
that peace of mind i mean that was such
a traumatic event doug and so if that
needs to look different for you i love
how you said that dave just give
yourself grace as you're walking through
this and all the emotions associated
with it yeah
so one of the things you got to remember
um like sometimes we talk about do i
sell mom's house after mom passed away
do i um
do i keep the farm after dad passed away
do i keep his whole pickup truck do i
um
what do i do with the uh wedding ring
from my
uh
first marriage
uh that i'm that i has bad memories of
right that kind of thing um all of these
things are
there's a reason we call it personal
finance um the mistake that people make
in the personal financial world is they
only do finance
but there's also personal yeah
and doug's situation you know it's a
very personal yes
hard
har unbelievably hard thing they are
going through have been through and does
that affect then the situation
it should
affect it
if you're a human yeah you know humans
hurt
and so you just got to factor that in
to to your equation now what you do want
to guard against is
that that becomes your new definition of
who you are and that's what i said you
know three months is great 30 months now
we're not walking our way through we're
just sitting in yeah
and so you need to be walking through
the bad stuff not staying yeah and uh
but it but give yourself a the wiggle
room to hurt yeah because it's part of
the equation
sadly in all our lives yeah christy good
hour thank you thanks for having me
christy wright number one best-selling
author the business boutique conference
is this coming weekend text boutique to
33 789 i'd love to see you there i'll be
speaking on friday
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
this is a special edition of the ramsey
show it is an entree leadership
theme hour what is entree leadership
well it's a combination of
entrepreneurship and leadership i wrote
a book 10 years ago this month called
entre leadership that became a number
one new york times bestseller
and it says on the cover 20 years of
practical business wisdom from the
trenches we should have changed the
cover because now it's 30.
so there you go so this is our playbook
on how we've grown ramsey how we run
ramsey why ramsay is always winning the
awards around best place to work why our
culture is so well known it's such a
great place to work our team is
incredible we're so proud of them um
and gosh
it is answering the questions for
businesses
of how do you run a business so if
that's your deal you got a question
about business you got a question about
the financial part of it fine the
management part of it fine the
production of an idea fine maybe you got
a success story maybe you did something
right out there in the world of business
we've been teaching and leading
thousands tens of thousands of small
businesses for about a decade
and uh it is a large part of what ramsay
does i love small business
it is the backbone of america
did you know that
75 of the new jobs created in the past
10 years have been by small businesses
not by big companies
most americans work for a small business
small business is one of the things we
call the great american dream home
ownership small business
building wealth these are the great
american dreams do you have to own a
business no you don't but side hustle
and hustle
capitalistic idea that if i serve
someone they pay me money
and they give me
certificates of appreciation with
presidents faces on them because i did a
good job for them
that's business
you're thankful when you do business
with a good small business
because they do a good job for you they
take care of you they cause our lives to
be better the people that run these
things it's a big deal
so if you're one of those folks and or
you want to be you've got questions
about starting one or you're talking
about hiring people even firing people
how do we do all that at ramsey well
i'll talk it through with you open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five an entree leadership
theme hour and of course you can learn
all about what we do with small
businesses at
ramseysolutions.com and just click on
entre leadership and we'll take good
care of you rick is in pensacola hi rick
welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks a lot dave huge fan man i've
been a fan of you for 15 years wow my
son's name is even dave wow did i name
my dad and my father-in-law after you
all time this is awesome
thank you that's tricky on your part
brother how can i help yeah
well my wife and i disagree on something
so i'm like i said i'm just so excited
to see what you have to say we own a um
successful business for four years now
and god has blessed it dude abundantly
we have at least a five-year business
plan yet and we want i want to put every
dollar back into the business
she wants to invest in other places like
an ira and i say why when you're doing
so much better with her own stock so
pretty much she wants to invest in the
stock market
i want to invest in livestock
okay um so what kind of business are you
in
actually we're in the zoo the zoo
business we um
yeah we own a zoo dave we literally
collect monkeys and have them on our
desk
that's what we do
that's fabulous
so this is a private zoo that the public
pays admission to come see
yes sir okay wow
yeah so um and so investing in
exotic animals in this case in order to
um
expand the offering of the zoo would be
what you're trying to do right
yes building more buildings building a
new gift shop building a vet thing like
all kinds of building in it and i want
to put every dollar back into it
okay but she wants security in something
else yeah
okay well we're killing it dave we're
blessed
that's a good thing that's a good thing
so um here's the deal
if you put um
20 000 bucks in a retirement plan in
good growth stock mutual funds uh if
that breaks your business and keeps you
from expanding
you're not killing it
right
you should still have money to expand
with
and we do okay but if i could put that
same twenty thousand dollars like i
literally just did a couple weeks ago
into a tortoise that is worth over a
hundred thousand dollars
that's where
yeah well that's an asset on the books
and it should increase cash flow
assuming people will pay
more people will come because you have
the tortoise you know or whatever you're
in your revenues at the gate go up and
so forth i don't know how that works but
i suspect that's how it works so yeah so
she's right you're wrong you lose the
argument but here's why
um i i did the same thing
our businesses
are like owning a single stock
we're putting all of our money in one
single stock when we don't have any side
investments and her security alarms are
going off because that's not very secure
uh and so it is it is something that we
all do in small business if we're not
careful because we love our business and
because
on a mutual fund you may make 10 or 12
or if it goes crazy 15
on on an investment inside a small
business you might make a hundred
percent or even 200 percent
and so it's really mathematically weird
but what we're not factoring in because
you and i have our hands on the hit on
the on the driver's uh and on the
steering wheel of this business we um
we don't factor in risk because we think
since we're driving it's going to be
okay right and so but here's the thing
the other thing that it sets you up for
a succession plan someday
uh someday
someone may
want to run the zoo that's not you like
one of your kids or something and
they want to yeah and if you had two
million dollars in mutual funds and
didn't need the money from the zoo and
it wasn't your only asset and your only
place to retire then it changes your
deal when you hand off stuff to the kids
okay so if and when i uh don't work
anymore which is not really a plan
but if that ever happened and i had no
income from this place
as a result the kiddos will be owning
the place because we uh we manage it for
god they're going to get the opportunity
management for god they're not paying a
dime for it
they're just going to take it because
i've got hundreds of millions of dollars
of other investments outside of here in
real estate and in mutual funds and so
i'm more than okay oh by the way if i
die tomorrow sharon doesn't get this
place she's got all those assets and the
kids are going to run this place
yeah okay and i'm able to do that
because i didn't only invest here
and it sets you up for a future there
and it lowers the risk
and here's the other thing proverbs 31
says and guys this is a great rule of
thumb in business
who can find a virtuous wife
for her worth is far above ruby's
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her
and he will have no lack of gain
assuming your wife is not just nagging
assuming she's virtuous
assuming she doesn't think she's the
holy spirit then you should listen to
her
because you will have no lack of gain
i'm convinced it's one of my secrets
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an entree leadership theme hour as
we talk with small business people the
best of the best across america the free
enterprise system is alive and well in
spite of the level of taxation we have
to operate in in spite of the
interfering level level of regula
regulatory control we have to operate in
in spite of all of that small business
is thriving
not because of it but in spite of it
because
if you want scrappy
you look up small business in the
dictionary and you see a picture of
scrappy
that's that's what it's all about so
entree leadership is the brand we use
here where we walk with and beside and
coach and teach and work with small
business people all across america for
that matter all the way around the world
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five nicole is in
traverse city michigan hi nicole how are
you
good how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm just wondering
is
it a good time to
take my home bakery business and move it
into a commercial space
um as a bakery and breakfast and lunch
cafe
during like this economy and this weird
like
times that we're going through
i think the answer to that might be
um
more local
than not
uh
translation um i live in a county
in tennessee
that is wide open
and um
there's very little
activity in this county that is in any
way restricted at this moment
um
and it's a fairly
pre-pandemic looking
feeling
when you walk down the street or when
you go into a store
okay other areas of the country that i
visit um
i was in five states in the last uh few
months in the last
last
15 days i guess something like that
and i've been in several states that uh
i felt like i was back in the middle of
the pandemic again because they're very
shut down and very closed up and very
um there and that environment is going
to be difficult to operate a bakery in
agreed and i i know traverse city it's a
wonderful city and i suspect you guys
are pretty wide open it's a resort area
and uh my friend meg meeker lives there
and and uh you know it's a it's a great
area uh and so i suspect the city itself
is probably pretty open uh you are in
the state of michigan which is cray-cray
right now
but um
on this issue but uh but that's that's
the environment you have to ask yourself
this question in right
yeah so if the governor leaves you alone
is traverse city going to leave you
alone and let you operate
okay yeah i mean i feel like
everything's been pretty open around
here and that's been the general route
that we seem to be headed towards yeah
but i mean
again if if every time
there's a spike in cases they shut down
businesses like yours this is a bad
environment start in agreed yes because
you're going to burn up capital on rent
that is unproductive you're going to
burn up capital on electricity you're
going to lose stock because you can't
get it baked and out the door
um and you can't get workers
um yeah and that kind of stuff so but if
you can operate fairly freely
maybe not 100 but 80 or 90
with freedom to have a quote normalized
operation unquote that gives you a
predictable environment
to do business in and uh when you when
you
interfere with the predictable
environment it makes it difficult to do
business that's what politicians don't
understand
it affects jobs it affects supply routes
it affects everything when they screw
with it uh but they're dumb and they
don't know these things so um you just
have to just have to laugh your head and
just laugh and shake your head at them
but that you know so to the extent you
feel like that freedom is gonna that
they're gonna give they're gonna stay
off of you
and let you operate is to the extent yes
now is a very good time
because everything that is open is
booming
and so we've got shortages of everything
because everything that's open is
booming anywhere in america and so it
just depends on the environment that
you're sitting in and um you know how
messed up they are
um
so uh and how you know it's fear-based
and i mean they're afraid
and i understand they're afraid i get
that and they want somebody hurt nobody
wants anybody to be sick i get all that
that's not the point but the point is
you've got to have a
um a predictable environment in order to
do business
so it's a good question if you've got
that i think it's a great time great
time jody's with us jody is uh with us
in edmonton alberta with a success story
tell me about what's going on good jody
so much is going on good dave sounds
like you guys are having a great day
down there yourself we are
yeah i was fortunate i heard of entre
leadership by accident in 2018. i
actually i hate to say i did not know
the dave ramsey show and i didn't know
entre leadership and my business was
struggling i didn't even know i was
struggling until my wife came on board
and she talked pretty regularly about
you dave she talked about you
patrick francione different people like
that
and i hate to say didn't i just couldn't
clue in i was one of those ball-headed
guys i just thought i was doing
everything right because it looked like
i was making money on paper and
almost led to a disaster but thank
goodness she uh she told me i should go
to the summit that you were having
it was in late april 2019 that was the
first time i ever heard you
speak oh wow
where was that one
that one was in san diego and it was
almost a bit of a disaster there too so
she was being very patient and very kind
with me and we got down to the hotel and
we had to miss your hotel of course it
was booked but i didn't understand how
those things worked back then
so we walked out the route to walk over
the night before figured it'd take about
half an hour from the hotel we were
staying at
and she said there's a special event you
might remember that so there's a special
event the night before we got to meet
out back to the hotel and they're going
to take us somewhere special
and dave i'm so embarrassed to say to
this day i saw you know what honey these
new tvs in the hotels i can get netflix
if you can believe that and that's the
state of mind that i was in
unfortunately and the next morning we
woke up and i was ready to go at 5 30
and my wife said no
and i said what she said no she said you
you kind of made up your mind so no
we'll just stay the hotel we'll just
miss this entire conference
and i got down on my hands and knees i i
recognized i was being a fool
and i said please honey i don't even
know what i was thinking can we please
go to this conference i don't know what
it's about but i would just love to go
see what you're all passionate excited
about so
she finally acquiesced and we got out of
bed and went over there it opened at
eight we got there at seven when the
doors opened because i want to make sure
i was trying to impress her that's the
thought i had
and i couldn't believe the energy and
excitement and when you bounded on stage
dave i tell you that was a life-changing
moment for our business right there my
wife already had it she had in her mind
because she'd been following you she'd
been reading your literature and your
information
finally i was able to see what she was
so passionate about
oh my goodness
well i'm honored and so uh you you were
doing uh
business well before you're doing okay
and now you're even doing better
i gotta tell you this
in 2018 it was our highest sales year
ever
and my worst profit ever because i was
chasing my tail i had people lined up
out my door i was unorganized my
business was unorganized i had no
mission statement i had no vision
statement we had really nothing except
for
my technical what were your what were
your top line sales that year
5.2 million what will they be this year
uh probably closer to four but our
profit is higher ah
very good very good and that's the thing
because she helped
through you through your organization
consistent podcasts reading going
through your entree leadership book
you know if if you even just take the
first three chapters of your book dave
and anyone that's listening i really
hope they pick it up just take the first
three chapters of your book and really
commit to that
you can totally transform your business
i was i was a treadmill operator that
you talk about and i was on that
treadmill hard yeah and it was bad and
i'm glad to say finally at the
pathfinder stage well i am so happy for
you jody thank you for sharing that
story that's absolutely amazing
yeah i remember the event you missed we
had the aircraft carrier
uh midway it's docked there in san diego
we had the whole aircraft carrier and we
had rock bands and stuff up on the deck
and it was iconic sorry you missed it it
was
it was an incredible opening event
standing on an aircraft carrier with
fireworks going off i mean who want what
more could any redneck want oh my gosh
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an entree leadership theme hour
here on the dave ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five it's a small business
theme hour in other words we're taking
questions from those of you that are
running businesses or want to and
questions about any part of the business
that's what we're here to help you with
luke is with us in pittsburgh hi luke
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you dave i don't know if i've ever
scripted the beginning of a conversation
before in my life until this moment so
i'm a huge fan you're my spirit animal
all right
just want to get that out of the way um
my question is um so my business right
now we're struggling with employees and
so
the easiest way to describe it is i feel
like we are set up for
double the amount of workers that we can
get right so our overhead was designed
to be spread out over more people
working that sort of thing and so
i'm trying to figure out how do you
i'm hoping the worker situation turns
around but if you make adjustments to
reduce overhead
and then you're not logistically set up
for more workers how do you find that
balance and what do you do in the in the
interim does that make sense yeah
yeah it makes a lot of sense most of us
are fighting with that right now
um there's approximately
uh
8 million people available for 10
million job offerings at this moment in
america
so if you want if you want to work in
america pretty much you are
um right i mean if you have reasonable
human
you know interaction skills and you
bathe regularly and that kind of stuff
you can get a job right now
so uh it's kind of ridiculous and the
pay has gone up substantially because
people are fighting over
uh labor and it's driving the price up
like a shortage on anything does labor
is not unlike other things on the supply
demand curve so that's what you're
fighting with what kind of business have
you got luke
uh so landscaping tree service and snow
removal business okay
all right i mean what
overhead have you picked up
uh for example so okay so from a
personal standpoint i got out of debt
back in april 27th we've been following
your plan and on on the business side of
things we've been working through
eliminating the debt that we had
accumulated there as well right so when
i say things like overhead for example
it's like some of the truck loans we
have are spread out over the different
teams but the front trucks are sitting
uh
one of them at any given day is sitting
at the moment oh we've been using the
nicest trucks well well we have
um so for example my vehicle can hold
more than one guy and then i'll end up
driving a trailer by myself because i
don't have somebody with me right right
though that's what i mean so most of the
trucks aren't sitting but sometimes a
lot of the equipment is we have the
equipment to add so there's not really
any way unless you've got equipment
that's sitting all the time you could
get rid of that but that's the only way
to lower the overhead and then not be
prepared when it turns back up which was
your question right
that is exactly my dilemma right
because anything else we do like i'd
have to restructure are you profitable
where you are today
uh some areas of the business are over
awesome or not we're working
uh as of right now we're right around
break even we are working through that
process as well to get more profitable
okay yeah you need well you're going to
sell some equipment then
because you have you have enough
equipment not in operation that your
lines have crossed and you got into a
negative
and then you know and so what you do is
just body i would take the
stuff that would be scheduled for
replacement first the most worn out
stuff and start moving it off the books
and use that to reduce debt and then
that'll get you closer to a break even
get you back up above break even and
then you just may have to
you you what we're having to do on
things is we just can't grow as fast as
we want to grow great because i just
can't get people to do the work that's
all it is and so i got 300 positions on
the books right now uh over half of them
technology
and uh programmers and um ruby on rails
folks uh you know all kinds of digital
marketing positions i've got them all
over the place and i'm not by myself
everybody does
uh and if you're trying to run a
restaurant or trying to run a golf
course god help you you can't it's hard
to get it's hard to get help
and uh and some of that is the biden
bucks had people sitting on the
sidelines and uh some of it is the
economy is just uh
you know a spiked post pandemic and uh
labor's labors just run to the highest
dollar which it'll always do by the way
and so um right
that's the whole process so i i if i'm
you here here's
in the name of
health business health
i'm going to trim down
and with that goes the admission that
when this thing when you get the
opportunity to grow again it's probably
going to slow down your growth
the only way i'm not doing that is if
you think you can fill these seats
with some butts
in the next 30 to 60 days and you can
hold on that way i'm trying some i know
you're trying but i'm asking can you
really do it and it's a very difficult
thing you're trying to do you know i
agree i get it but for guys that are
go-getters that leave the cave kill
something and drag it home the idea of
growing slower is really painful
yes
i'm i'm the same way
i was in a meeting this morning going
get this freaking a project out the door
what's wrong with you people they're
like we can't get it staffed we need two
squads to do it right now and you know
it's developers and
you know as digital marketers and your
cases people riding lawn mowers but it
doesn't matter you just got to get a
staff then uh it never and oh by the way
i have never
in 30 years of running this business
been fully staffed
i've always had more ideas and growth
than i could get people always always
been trying to catch title wave with the
teacup
so it's it is the nature of the beast of
the small business
and uh the the the uh but the hardest
thing is to put a bridle in your own
mouth and say i'm gonna grow slower so
that i stay healthy i'm gonna grow
slower so that i stay healthy the
tortoise wins i just have to repeating
that over and over and over to myself
the tortoise always wins not the hair
the tortoise always wins not the hair
rob's in cleveland ohio hey rob what's
up
not much how are you good how can i help
i have two boys 12 years old 10 years
old they started a lawn mowing business
last year
they did really well last year they did
even better this year they registered
their trade name with the state they did
not register an llc or anything like
that
they need liability insurance because
dad doesn't want to foot the bill if
something bad happens
and we can't get it because they're
minors
minors can't contract for anything in
any state
so what do we do so they don't own a
business
you do
12 year olds can't sign for an llc in
ohio
they they right they don't have an llc
but they have a registered trade name
yeah in their name
in their names means absolutely nothing
except protects their name it protects
their name and it's i mean there's two
there's two or three things going on
you're trying to talk about a business
structure and a liability issue and a
legal issue in the midst of teaching
your sons how to work hard which is
great and how to run a business which is
great that's my main concern
you know if you want to cover the
liability you're going to have to open
it drop it into an llc in your name and
you're gonna have to buy insurance and
you own a business and your sons work
for it because they can't contract for
anything
okay that's how you'll have to
technically cover it um then the
question just becomes is how much
liability do you really have
with a couple of you know a couple of
teenagers with a lawn mower
i mean most of the dangers probably to
themselves
frankly
um but the uh i don't know i mean i
guess they could throw a rock through
something right
well in my i look at it if they break a
window hey we pay for the window that's
not a big deal but if we if we throw a
rock and we injure somebody
that's a whole different story and they
you know they're growing big enough
they're getting you know they're buying
bigger equipment they're doing these
things that you know are the real deal
yeah not just two kids with a lawnmower
yeah okay
and what is your net worth
um
half a million okay do you have a
million dollar umbrella of liability on
you
i do not okay you pick that up for a
couple of hundred dollars and talk to
your insurance broker when you're doing
that if that will cover this issue
because these kids are not liable you're
liable
because you're the adult
they're they're in your custody you're
the custodian you have to talk to your
attorney to verify that i'm right but i
am
um and so
um yeah your liability umbrella might
cover you if you want to get super
careful you could open an llc and buy a
buy an insurance policy on it but it's
all going to be in your name but but
you're liable anyway because they're not
they're in your care you're responsible
for the behavior of your children
legally
and so if they mess something up they
don't get sued you do
and so that that is the worry and it's a
valid worry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 21 21
whoever pursues righteousness and love
finds life
prosperity and honor
warren buffett said it takes 20 years to
build a reputation in five minutes to
ruin it if you think about that you'll
do things differently
agreed
right now you're probably focused on all
the fall stuff that you've got to buy
halloween christmas thanksgiving it's
all happening right and christmas seems
to sneak up on people like they move it
or something now christmas is always
there
so you don't need to wait you don't need
to put it on a credit card for goodness
sakes
you need to get on a budget and plan
ahead keep christmas from getting out of
control the best way to do that is with
our world-class
budgeting tool
the app
every dollar
start your christmas budget right now by
deciding how much you want to save each
month and plug it into your every dollar
budget so you can pay for christmas in
cash
then when you start shopping your every
dollar
app makes it easy to keep up with it and
how much you're spending on gifts and
it's totally free
you can upgrade
to ramsey plus membership and get the
premium features like bank sync that
allows you to drag and drop your
transactions right into your budget
and all kinds of custom reports to show
you where your money's going christmas
is coming it is not a surprise
this year you can enjoy the holiday
stress free
start budgeting and that'll cause it to
happen use every dollar text budget to
33 789 and we'll set you up
budget
to three three
seven
eight nine
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money it
is a
free call it is andre lee and entre
leadership theme hour as we're talking
with and about small business what does
it take to run a business in america
today and continue to be profitable in
all the wildness and craziness we've got
out there it's a wild wild time out
there and
jason is with us in montana hi jason i
see on the screen you got a success
story tell me about your business
i do dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve sir what's up
well i came to
uh entree leadership
not knowing who in the world dave ramsey
was
i i stumbled into it through the podcast
very very interesting and since then
this is in early 2018.
in early 2018 i had just recently
purchased a
successful
business
in telecommunications
and
i needed to be able to get something to
be able to continue to grow this
business
and myself uh the entry leadership
podcast was
that ticket uh to date i've listened to
every
published episode of the entree
leadership podcast
read your book been to many of your
conferences been to the headquarters uh
have
great relationships with all of the
teams and
to give you the idea of how these
principles work
uh applying all of the principles and
everything
we continue year over year
to
grow we did first year was 2.3 million
we'll do
close to 5 million this year
where we only had projected 4.3 wow
that's great
our
uh i have an amazing team
and this is all because we treat people
well we treat people how we want to be
treated
and we just garner every single
principal um here recently i went
through a
kind of a unique situation i actually
sold a lot of uh my company to
uh an electric cooperative
in that sale
i continue on as the ceo um and
my team
was built well enough off the entre
leadership principles
that we have charged right through it
didn't even show a hiccup
um
and with that sale the
uh second half of it is my wife and i
get to garner true ramsey principles and
we are 100
debt free way to go dude that's awesome
well congratulations what a great place
to be
so what do you think in the in the last
period of time that you've been working
on this business and you've seen these
changes
what do you think the one or two most
important things you picked up were
it's absolutely about core values and
with the right people on the bus yep
it is with the we we hire around our
core values we teach our core values we
do monthly staff meetings
um we communicate with everybody but
it's definitely all about having the
right people on the bus to help
you charge forward because
we can't do it by ourselves there's no
way to do it by ourselves
and having this team of people has just
been absolutely amazing to see what they
can do when i step out of the way
oh amen
amen
well congratulations on that that is a
hard thing our friend jim collins of
course in the book good to great
originated the idea got the right people
on the bus the wrong people off the bus
are right people on the right seats on
the bus is one of the parts of the
recipe to having a great great company
i assume you had some painful exits in
order to arrive at this place though
absolutely every you know there's
there's always people that you have to
say you have to look them in the eye and
say
i'm sorry you can't work here anymore
the but everything was done with grace
and therefore
there's no hard feelings
we've given everybody an absolute
opportunity to shine
and when the light doesn't shine we try
to garner we try to show them the exit
as
uh politely as we possibly can and that
has worked for us very well yeah you're
not we're not mad at you you're just not
a we
we do it this way and you aren't so
you're not a we
and uh you get to decide if you're gonna
be a we it's a con there's consequences
to not being one and
um but yeah you're right and teaching
the core values regularly uh i i did our
staff meeting this morning with a
thousand almost 1100 people here and um
i spent 15 minutes on one of our core
values and taught on it and um and just
remind everybody this is who we are and
if you want to be a we this is who we
are decide every day you get to redecide
that because we don't want folks here
that are just working at job
uh if your spirit leaves this building
you ought to take your body with it
absolutely yeah and you've obviously
done that kind of stuff as well and it
is difficult uh it's painful because uh
sometimes it's folks get angry sometimes
they don't understand no matter how
careful you are how polite you are how
generous you are
that they make up lies uh because they
just can't face themselves and they
can't face their own inability to
perform on something and it's just
really really tough but you still uh you
look back on you go i i wouldn't trade
the collection of folk i've got right
now for the collection of folk i used to
have not a chance i'm making that trade
so it's worth the uh worth the pain of
doing that and uh aligning ourselves
with you know what ken coleman teaches
to find people who are
functioning in their passion their their
functioning in their sweet spot as king
calls it jason very very good to talk to
you i'm very proud of you
congratulations on all your success
thank you sir appreciate you calling in
and sharing that with us so business
principles are not as difficult as some
people make them out to be the idea of
running a business you know most of it
does revolve around the golden rule
you know it's not who has the gold makes
the rules that's and that's not one time
i'm talking about truly treat other
people like you won't be treated
so
if you have a website up
go visit your website
and go through the experience your
customers going through
and you will find stuff that will
frustrate you
go to one of your locations
anonymously
and have the experience your customer is
having
you sometimes you'll be very proud and
sometimes you'll be very frustrated
treat other people like you won't be
treated
oh by the way that's part of your team's
deal too you pay them you pay them on
time
you give them the dignity of their
personhood while
still addressing the behaviors that have
to change
this is how this works
it's really not rocket science but it's
hard to do
over a long period of time and that's
why so few people succeed over a long
period of time
in business but it's doable the entree
leadership theme hour in the books our
thanks to james childs and kelly daniels
in the booth i am dave ramsey your host
will be back with you before you know it
in the meantime remember there is
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you